bonjour Laurent Salim bonjour Stéphane
comment ça va bien ce matin
pardon Laurence
ensemble sur sur une autre chaîne voilà
c'est un crash en
directine jeune vendeuse
je peux avoir
normalement
salut Marion bonjour salut Alain bonjour
ça va ça va et toi et vous vous voyez
non mais très rapidement je me suis
corrigé moi-même heureusement parce que
j'ai quasiment vu des flammes sortir de
ses yeux quoi à ce moment-là c'était où
est-ce que Léa peut parler cher Benoît
ça c'est trop facile
on voit bien que Clovis parle
extrêmement doucement
[Rires]
je suis en stage pour devenir une star
quand je vois l'emploi du temps chargé
comme ça je me dis ok la vie de star
c'est bien compliqué hein non laisse
tomber genre il y a sport le matin
ensuite essayage ensuite il y a prise de
tonna ensuite il y a danse ensuite je me
repose quand et regardez notre homme du
jour qui brille lui sur les plateaux de
cinéma l'acteur américain Chris Evans
vient de faire des jaloux à Hollywood à
41 ans il décroche les titres d'hommes
le plus sexy du monde tout simplement
celui qui incarne le Captain America
succède à palourde autre super héros ce
nom d'hautman bien sûr et tu crois non
moi je pense que j'étais en prison ils
ont mis un homme d'accord pour rien sans
raison sept ans
mais je mérite de la je suis pas tout
seul ils ont pas le temps [ __ ] me dis
pas que tu as rien volé tu aurais pas
mis en tonne 7 ans
je te dis mais tu as compris pourquoi je
gagne de l'argent c'est grâce à vous
mais quand on tourne c'est c'est vrai tu
es concentré
mais pas du tout
mais non il a juste été mis au point une
ou deux fois pendant le tournage
je ne peux pas l'enlever parce que les
deux micros sont sur la neige
que si je transpire c'est pas parce que
je suis gros c'est parce que j'ai chaud
comment vous vous appelez-vous nous
sommes deux membres des screen match
people on voit très très bien les deux
membres actuels
c'est un Britannique qui est un énorme
problème est-ce que vous savez est-ce
que vous pouvez savoir est-ce que vous
voulez savoir lequel ah oui ça y est je
vous dire que c'est vrai c'est pas une
vanne de la taille de son sexe 24 cm au
repos c'est 23 cm de plus que Benjamin
énormément de difficultés dans son
quotidien c'est un véritable handicap il
a même échappé un emploi à cause de ça
si jamais tu as besoin d'un peu plus de
confort n'hésite surtout pas c'est très
important mais ils font des jeans de
plus en plus et par le pas et sinon tu
peux aussi tu vois si tu t'en bats les
costumes merci beaucoup le mot d'ordre
du jour faites ce qu'il vous plaît et
venez comme vous êtes
[Musique]
celui-là on m'a demandé de le garder
pendant un moment on est toujours
content d'aider les gens sur ce genre de
choses
[Musique]
voici que France Bleu nous apprend qu'à
Vesoul il n'y a plus de siffler en bois
pour mettre dans les cochons de la
Sainte Catherine je demande à quitter
cette planète tout de quoi alors je
rassure les amis les animaux évidemment
les cochons de la Sainte-Catherine ce
sont des gâteaux en pain d'épice pas de
vrais porc mais j'avoue que c'est ce qui
m'a fait cliquer je me détiens a besoin
on fournitifs non
[Rires]
[Musique]
dis-moi qu'est-ce que j'ai moi ce que
j'ai entre les dents de si craquant tu
es sûr tu veux garder ce pantalon
je vais les garder là parce que dis-moi
ce que j'ai entre là je
[Applaudissements]
moi ça fait 5 ans que je suis ici et
c'est du jamais vu le
[Applaudissements]
il y avait DJ Snake et maintenant il y a
DJ Snake
[Applaudissements]
aux
là sur la vue
rien d'y penser ça me pique oui parce
que oui ça dépend les femmes moi j'ai
vécu et on a été accouché par le même il
avait le scalpel facile
pour une fois nous avons un film où vous
voyez et j'en viens à votre bus puisque
vous voulez l'anecdote du buste
Elisabeth
[Rires]